we've begun with this oh there's my
favorite quadratic of all time okay the
first thing I asked you to do is pretty
pedestrian just the factorization that's
all I'm after so can someone give me
heads up who's already got the
factorization there it down yes it was
three yeah okay down XS 3x plus 3 and X
plus 2 will do for me yeah by the way
how do we know you've got two choices
right number one you can just expand
back like I can expand the brackets and
i'll get x 5x plus 6 it'll work
alternatively like what are these
numbers two or three how do we select
them what access they add to add to the
five right and 25 and they multiply to
sit okay good good what it all right
down that's fine i just want you to keep
that in your back of your mind let's
have a look at B now you have to do two
things first you have to evaluate right
so you've seen this function notation
before it means you're going to take X
plus 2 and set it substituted everywhere
you saw X like this is a fairly
straightforward suggestion let's just
give it a go so use me f of X plus this
first slide before i do any expanding
I'm literally just going to write down
the substitution so everywhere CX
there's an X plus 2 and there's another
X plus 2 happy with that it's nothing
too traumatic that's happened there in
order to get to this part the sorry this
part the factorization I've got to
expand this first and they don't get
something which looks a bit like this
right it'll be a general form and then I
can repeat this process right think of
my pair of numbers so let's just quickly
go ahead and do that X plus 2 all
squared what's the extension that x
squared plus 4x plus 4 here there's a
pretty simple expansion as well 5x plus
the 10 plus 6 so far so good yeah okay
so let's have a look that's tiny to
speak up like toes have my god how many
x squared times do I have it the whole
food form I just had the one so i have
to worry about him I've got four X term
there the next term
yeah so they're going to come together
and then you've got a whole bunch of
cuts the terps flying around one two
three have I counted all up I look it
okay so let's so let's collect it as you
said there's just x squared term for x +
5 x 9 x 4 plus 10 plus 6 that's 20 and
now ready to factorize right what's the
pair of doubles a laptop five and four
them do for me sir ax plus 45 okay
excellent good keep that the back of a
line and let's just quickly do see the
process is exactly the same so let's see
if we do this a little bit quicker f of
X mode is soo because of familiar with
this same function I'm just going to go
ahead and I'm going to go to this line
right what's the same of what's
different what the front i'm going to
have X minus 20 squared X minus 2 all
squared so that's almost like this right
the only difference is you're going to
get a minus 4x in the middle you care of
that that's my X minus 2 all squared now
I'm going to add 5 watts off X minus 2
this time rather than X plus 2 okay so
that's going to give me five X minus 10
there's that minus 2 which has become a
minus 10 instead of a bust em and then
you've got this plus 6 still hanging on
the end yep don't look all right should
we collect like terms how many x squared
terms do I have just the x squared so
i'll just write down hit 0 minus 4x plus
5x minus 4 plus 5 that leaves me with a
single X and what happens to my
constants cancel yeah I get the the for
the six or 10 you always look for a did
you guys learn we are you old enough to
have friends of 10 friends attend anyway
whenever you're adding up a whole bunch
of numbers right so I got seven numbers
to add up you think if the ones that add
up to 10 first because they're easy to
do because that brings are pretty good
that so things that my primary school
daughter has taught me so 4 plus 6 is TM
takes away 10 and then you're done right
so so in fact I'm worried
okay ready to factorize what's my
factorization you just take out a factor
X for this one right and that leaves you
in X plus 1 okay so far so good now this
is our backdrop here right I what I'm
going to use these three results excuse
me and what I'm really interested in is
not just for this particular example of
f of X right this particular function
what if I had any functions like you
know loads of functions right for
instance I could have said how about
this that's another function the square
root of x or how about this guy 2 to the
power of X right or three of the power
of X or any other kind of animal excuse
me thinking you know how to graph right
for any of these what happens when I do
this right just put it like a plus 2
there or minus 2 what's actually taking
place what effect did that have on this
up these results of functions of these
results in gratis okay now the resulting
to show you is kinda counterintuitive if
I can intuitive like what I mean is it's
the opposite of what you might expect
and your intuition says oh I think it
should do this but the truth is it ends
up doing exactly the opposite so I'm
going to try and convince you a very
counterintuitive thing and I'm going to
do it three ways okay three ways so that
hopefully one of them at least one of
them will convince you okay because I'm
all the way even to your 11 and 12
students find this confusing so that's
what I'm going to try and give you a lot
of a lot of evidence right